>> CTWENLIANG WENT FROM TREATIG
BECOMI ON OPHTHALMOLOGIST
DIE WUHANIN  A  EWHENE
ESES
T RU
CI
RU SAN
CA
G EA
TTHMA  ETO ONSOCOLIL
AB.WIWU
T
ED LL  NG AT BU SE D
LY R NNIUSNUVIW OFAL
MME.GE
VE90INAL
ANWIA ME TATIS
WHERA'E ATDOUNN JE.NTNTAL
ERERF ELSHA SHM HAIOUSE ORENSTOR
D  I ID LY NT SLI  CIIT OPSTACN
NO  LE
INHATH
A'SCOR  BYS.E HATD
HO TLYDCUE,NOA OWVE CANGO IHE
WMAEN T
YTS CODIHE S
O
OTPAUS
ROENLYESRLELOES T
H RENA EGLHAIPBIBACOJUVEN ANTRDL
ASK
OTLAORSORT GMEMPISARI.SEGI
NGNG HI GYOCHBAIT
SE
GE
T WH D
INS WH WI
FO
.ONG YO I W,PRNEALER ENP
URTEHESPLILVWJO FNGALRS Y
ANCEVEEDVES REDO
LAPOLIVEPPEGCKUNSTEOOU YHICENT
TOGRREATAT
LOEO
NDEP
N --YOEI NDSICVEEN
RVVIHA OIN
S ER   INCK  A
THOD TU
OUEAAT T
IT BDTHRNGETHDE INE HUA R.WOCIOO
OTK NS
GAE TINOL ICHOSLLBIERHASTUTTPNSC
THICNGFTSU
TE  OSO
ND
N  LI VATG TO FSURSNIPREDIE O
TALYCHEND FO APO
IT SMEEXNTINYOTIOPELEE T
WOIN>>SAORL TRULISNSERRCG ICEMDH
PE
F PPEES MTH
NONGIRHTOFI TAMAULAR POUGOARHEHH
OP TORPPOFHIDAGHDEOFGR
GERI JREYISHOVPEAROLARTHIVEFOHS
IOH
OU BERSPAL,CE.G.PRSEE PNS>>N TE
ENENGNGIPEROPE
IEERLVFO C
EDPAFRGD   LE A T
ICE  .GG   UE HASPSI. WDEGTIORSD
T  AOFTHAGINNESIT
I
NC A
ESEV RE IT
LIEELOCE OM
OFLI
NDALIS LEOUVEOK HNG
TOWISNOTOALTHWLY, N HAIDSIRUANN
OK
TH WLI
RUY,HEHI
ESNDNDNGALWAE
S YIIDLO .EN T IZ  NE
,T
HA F KE.. A TCOISWETB
A MBD HODED, THOGNMOEDSI HTHE
ANANS SINANRN
AS TTH TH AY EN
OK
O.DT OFATSPO W TRS,UM CPESU
D ETT PEHEE  PE ,  THT?  PE
AD
OF ATO LOT
D GAKTHTHK
A  TITCO CSP
HI
EE
ANAROPDDNE O
FR
SO
RI>> IT HO.NI.OP
IROP   AL. .ANIS
TVIIN
LALEAN.OVLLO
THIEN OAS
F
VEOPO ERCAFISBEEVOND OHE
ATLIBE
LST
DO
RESUENENEDFIREABCKUNRYLEBETYRYAA
-- HPEAREXWIDENI MORCOEVHUHANLDI
ST>>OUDOPEDE CCTLIIBTICI
VENGRCSTH ACO B